jeff for this interview you've you've
touched on so many different parts of
your courses in your book i'm wondering
if you can talk a little bit more about
what you will be incorporating into your
what is your two year program that
you've launched okay
and and how that benefits writers
yeah uh
it's the same tools that i've always
been teaching but
what i used to do was
30-hour in intensive weekends or 30
hours like every tuesday night three
hours for 10 weeks
and the tools are complex and
sophisticated so that
fire hose teaching is not
at all the best way to instill deep
know-how
with these tools
and i
wanted to really find a much better way
to teach
so that
i spent a couple years just thinking
about how to
teach it differently and to teach bigger
groups
because it was always limited to six
because i
felt like i had to really get each
person using the tool on their own
script
so they could
get experience
using the tools properly and see their
stories respond to it
the word of mouth for those classes was
through the roof
because
people loved the tools
they got a chance to really use them and
their scripts improved quite a lot
but
i felt like they
couldn't go home and use these tools
with expertise
you know it's like somebody
teaching you how to build a rocket and
get it to the moon
you have to really study every part of
it and break it down and integrate it
and synthesize it into a
comprehensive expertise
so you know i really studied the science
of learning and
the science of training people and
expertise and
and the science of cognitive
apprenticeship
and
found a way to teach
a large group of people
over a much longer amount of time i
found that i could
turn people into seasoned versatile
dramatists who could
make scripts work of any genre and could
tackle any medium
and so
you know it's a it's a
high-intensity training program
and
it's still the hands-on
intensive process that i've always done
but i've opened it up quite a bit
so
the core of the program
the one thing that i'm actively doing as
i teach
is an 18-month period
where
all we're doing is constantly working on
maybe six to eight different scripts of
different genres and at different stages
of development
so that
one day we'll be working on an action
comedy the next day it might be a
thriller and so on so we're continually
changing gears and moving from script to
script so you get
you get experience with different genres
and
and even different mediums one will be
for a screenplay one will be a tv series
one will be a stage play
and one of them we're just starting out
one of them is mostly done
and everybody's working as a group and
they're still doing
writing assignments and exercises and
learning games
and there's like
group problem solving like if we're
stuck
at the end of
you know a thriller trying to figure out
how the murder actually goes down
maybe we'll spend a whole week on it and
are completely stumped
and so we have group problem solving
where
i'll have everybody
coming up with ideas that you know like
their assignment would be to go home and
come up with 20 different ways
to pull off this murder and then look at
your 20 ideas and sort the best ones to
the top
and then put those best ones into the
group and then everybody works together
to sort those
best ones to the top so we may end up
with 20 or 30 phenomenal ideas the best
of the best and we all look at those and
go wow these are really great
this one could really solve our problem
this one solves it and opens up an
interesting stuff that would make us
complicate the story earlier on it like
opens up a whole lot more
this one is so good we should set it
over here and make a whole script out of
it on its own
but it makes the students
do the work themselves
it's not about them sitting back and
watching me do this stuff
it's about me making them as proactive
as possible
so that the more expertise they acquire
the more their integral integral to the
process
so that
if we
come to like a horror film that's partly
developed there might be a team of
advanced students who are actively
working on that every day
and we say like oh so how's it going in
there say well we solved this
now we're stuck here we use this tool
and so and so came up with this
phenomenal idea and it's it's fun and
we're doing great but we're stuck here
and then everybody is participate on
that as a group and there might be a
teaching moment where i end up giving a
whole lecture on this particular aspect
of one tool
and that
teaching lecture becomes part of the
permanent teaching library that anybody
can go to at any time
and i'm
basically
turning these students into rough and
tumble
experts who can really tackle anything
sometimes i feel like i'm training them
to be like rodeo clowns or something
because i don't know if you know this
but rodeo clowns are
high skilled gymnasts they're like
really really
technically proficient and
really i mean they go up against a 1600
pound bull to distract it to rescue the
rider and like they like grab a fence
and leap they're like
unbelievably skilled and rough and ready
and can tackle anything and and so it's
like that kind of
versatility and flexibility and attack
and
high degree of skill in multiple highly
technical tools
and you can throw them into a comedy or
a horror film or a thriller
and they're like i got this and that's
what i'm that's what they're all
building toward
and so
really i only do one thing and that's
this open workshop where we're
constantly building scripts
and that's all we're doing and that's
how i train people
and
there's definitely teaching moments here
and there as they come up
but it's about
learn by doing it's a real
apprenticeship we're really building
real scripts in real time
and
the challenge that i had when i when i
when i was wrestling with how do i teach
larger groups and teach differently
the question that finally freed me up
was okay so if i could wave a magic wand
and teach any way i wanted to
what would i do instead of stuck in all
the limits and how do i get out of this
it was like no no no
if i just could wave a magic wand and do
anything no limits no anything i was
like okay well
i'd take two years and really train
the crap out of them like really train
them
and then okay so if it's a two-year
program
how do i make it so the big question was
how do i make it so people can join in
because that you know it's like you hear
about the program and i want to join
them i'm sorry it's another 14 months
before the next one starts that doesn't
work so i was like okay so how can it be
a continuously ongoing
open workshop where we're just building
scripts all the time
how do i make it so anybody can join in
at any time so i said okay so
if there was a three-month training
program
that's basically a pre-recorded video
and it's
the building of a complete script in
those three months
it's kind of like a
flight simulator
where
you
take this three-month video program and
i start on day one with a one sentence
idea for a thriller
and we're
by the end of the day one we've already
got an idea up and running we're looking
at her dilemma already
and then and they have exercises and
learning games and assignments
but not too much but it's it's intensive
and
then day two
we're building more and it's all me on
video talking to them
but i'm giving them assignments and
trying to make them as proactive as
possible and they're copying down the
use of the tools
and learning how to think
and seeing and and participating in the
creation of this story and even though
they can't participate in the actual
creation of it because it
that three-month class may have been
recorded two years ago
i still give them professional
assignments
say okay so
she's stuck in this room
and this person is watching her but
she's got to get a message to so and so
or she's dead
i don't know how to do that your
assignment is go home and come up with
20 different ways she might do that
and i'll show up the next day with my
solution for that and i can't interact
with what they did
because this was recorded years ago
but they had to really wrestle with the
problem and really think it through
so i'm trying to make them as
proactive and as involved in the process
as possible
and as we use all the tools and they end
up hand copying all the sequence
proposition plot we do as we construct
it
and then once we've done it
we've done it for the overall story
they've hand copied that done a free
check they've hand copied that
just a few pages each day
due to all the sequences and then we
come to the first scene and we structure
that scene and they actually write that
scene
and then the next day we structure the
next scene and they write that scene we
go all the way through
and they
each person writes their own version of
this thriller
and when that's when they've got their
own version that graduates them into the
18-month program
so it's a way to
give them enough exposure
to the process see all the tools in
action they're not tasked with trying to
learn the tools their main job is to
observe everything
to get oriented so they see the whole
process
and then when i'm training them
intensively
in the 36 dramatic situations and
they're like
i hate this why is he having us do this
over and over again
they're not going i hate this they're
going oh i see how immensely valuable it
is because we did it there and so
not only are they oriented and they've
seen the whole thing so they understand
how each part
functions as part of the whole
but when they come out of that
three-month video recording program they
can jump into the 18-month program and
we may be spending the whole week
figuring out the ending of a romantic
comedy and they can jump right in they
know
they understand sequence proposition
plot dilemma all these things it's not
foreign to them so they can jump right
in and participate so that means
in this ongoing 18-month thing they can
join in at any time
and then as they acquire more and more
expertise
and i give more and more responsibility
to them
and challenge them more
and they always have to be able to
articulate their thinking process as
they wrestle with the tools so that the
experts toward the end of the 18 months
i can say to them as they're wrestling
with the ending of a ghost story
i'd say okay so articulate what you're
thinking and they'd be like well okay so
we have a good strong dilemma but we're
still struggling with the crisis we have
this this and this for the crisis and
i'd say have you thought of that and
they'd be like good point they'd throw
they're not thrown or i'd say like wait
you did that wrong and they're like
well so what i'd be like this this and
they go oh of course like they're
they're almost there you know they're
like and everybody's learning from that
and and the more and more expertise them
the more they don't need me
my
instructional voice is internalized into
their own process
they can emulate my thinking process
they can emulate they have the
metacognitive skills to evaluate their
own professional process
so they can be like i'm doing the
technique properly
but i shouldn't even be focusing on that
because here's the main question
so to be able to challenge their own
professional skills
and kick themselves out of bed and
reverse
their own
trajectory and all that is important
then in order to graduate from the
program
they do the last three months which is
to
build a script on their own still in
this open workshop
and we've been throwing ideas that
people don't so much care about into the
group's story band and even working on
them so they pick an idea from the
group's story bin
develop it
build it
in an open workshop that's open to
everybody and it's like a teaching
hospital where all come by with the
whole group and go how's it going where
are you at and they'd be like well i
solved this oh that's great that was a
hard hump to get over and they like tell
me about it and
this is the tool i'm using now here's
where i'm stuck
i may have some insight or i might say
wow that's brilliant and the other
students may have questions and they're
articulating their thought process
and when they complete that script they
can graduate and they take that script
with them it's theirs
or they could if they want more they can
do another one like that or they can
also
stay in the group and they may like
collaborating with the people they've
been through with and they can be in
private sessions where they still have
this as like their writer's group and a
coffee shop and they have people who can
read their drafts and brainstorm with
them
so that
that kind of
interactive capability with people who
know the same tools is there for
graduates
and it's it's not open to the other
people because they want to be really
working their scripts now but they may
like the
the community
so that's an option too
so it's really the 18-month there's
three months to get into it it's kind of
like if you're going to go up and work
on the space station
nasa will put you through a training and
then you can go up in the space station
you're not going to get people killed
and you can operate in 0g and you know
know how to function in an emergency and
all that stuff and then the last three
months
you do it all on your own which
completes this the synthesis of all your
skills and your abilities and your you
know your your functionality
to where you feel like you can go off
and do your own thing or stick around
and keep working with you know the same
community
in a private format that's not open to
the whole group but you can still
interact with people
so that's the basics of it
it's been fun to create it's been really
challenging
and just
trying to figure out all the things and
integrate all the new learning
techniques that i've found and
keep challenging myself and
it's been
still is i'm still in the middle of
creating it and it's
it's fascinating again it was i got
burned out on teaching the same thing
non-stop for 18 years it was really good
to get a break and now it's really fun
to come back into it
you